Bộ bác người bị lừa gần 1 trong tì động việp 1 tắc đạo thành tiên.
Bật phẩm pháp hí ra 2 trong năm nay,
nền động được thuổi phòng thành năm tì động vẫn có người mua,
chỉ cần tu sông thịt cách gì có cái đấy vàng bạc kinh cường có đủ.
Bảo bảo là mình là tu tập đẹp mà đất đạo thì tìm bắt bộ thiệt.
Cái nơi dừng nối thì mà chúng em mà tu tập kèvun rất theo ké pháp tu của chúng,
thì chúng đặc đạo ké gì có cái đấy thịt bạng bạc kinh cường thì đều có đầy đủ.
Khi vào đây là bạn trong em là có bà bên bếm,
thì nơi bảo là,
với tuổi đấy thì nơi rất là kỳ đối với gia đình em thì bây giờ phải chắn,
thì phy dùng cái là bạn về chắn,
hãy còn phải là bắt phói đồ này cho mọi thứ được viên,
tính này là năm tìm bà,
còn một cái trong ké là 2 tìm bạy,
và một cái 2 tìm giới.
Nó nói với trở về em,
đúng là tổng mừng nhà em cũng có những vòng,
nó chạy có nó cứ đi theo em,
nó đi thời bọn em rất là loa lắm,
thế là trong em ở đâu,
nó phương phát,
nó ra về này chỉ chỉ bị chắn,
thì các chính giận cũng như học trên mặt,
trên đặt này cho mấy phịt,
tôi là là nhiều cái,
và mèo tạp,
cái đồng tin,
với tên xe phụ trong lọc trên mỗi khoảng miếng lãn,
thì vào tôi là người tổng vài,
mới thêm bị đỏ,
tìm mua cái pháp phí vệ,
để bán là người bị thải,
để ai chỉ cho có chính xúc.